tried to connect rain here the guy who
had a talk with Cliff he's here so why
would he say that if he's not God
himself if he doesn't have the power to
do all these things then why would he
call himself God the answer that we have
is he doesn't you're more than welcome
to come up
bro it's
God it's
God how you doing I'm good how are you I
am fantastic you said I'm tired
sorry you sound real chill yeah um you
know before we go into this whatever I
just want to be very clear um I am no
not an expert by any means there's many
things regarding to Islam I do not
understand there's many things regarding
to Christianity I do not understand but
I think there are a few misconceptions
that you have made that I would love to
talk about and have a civil conversation
about um I promise I will not interrupt
you I will give you your time to speak I
will wait a second until after you
finish your sentence there say anything
and I hope you'll give me that same
respect back and we can actually you
know gain something from disc discussion
I don't do discussions I don't do
debates in order to win or to gain
followers or for clout I do it because I
genuinely would like us to both learn
something by the end of this same sound
good to you sounds perfect man that's my
perfect so the first question I have is
that what do you think that Christian
Arabs call
God uh they call him Allah okay okay so
if a Christian Arab came across your
life you realize they would not agree
with you corre no they do because they
know what I'm talking about they know
that I'm saying that the Allah of the
Quran in Islam is not God okay that's a
better clarification so you're saying
the god of who revealed the Quran upon
Muhammad sallallah alaihi wasallam is
not God correct that's your premise okay
why do you say that well there are some
qualities that um I believe that God has
like all powerfulness you know the Omni
properties that doesn't have I don't I
don't believe that he's all powerful as
described in the Quran what does all
powerful mean to you can you describe
that capable of doing every any
everything logical every logical Poss
he's able to do okay what would be an
example of That So like um I've been
asking this question to the previous
guests if Allah can have a
son okay yeah I understand so like an
example of the reason I ask this
question is sometimes people have the
idea or give an attribute to God called
unlimited would you agree with
that say that again would you agree that
God is
Unlimited in in what aspect in the
aspect of being all powerful Unlimited
in power in a sense that he he God
cannot become limited God is an
unlimited the beginning of creation
nothing created he is unlimited yeah so
Unlimited in power in that sense and
also in the sense that he is a unlimited
creation you cannot put bounds on him
and you cannot Tech technically in any
sense in any Scripture you cannot
actually Define exactly what God is
because he's outside of the realm of
human comprehension in many
ways
um we we can apprehend that he is
infinite like can you comprehend the
will of the father do you know what the
will of the father is I know what the
will of the father is now do I in its
entirety you know exactly why God does
everything and why I I I know so I I
don't know uh exactly so understanding
of God is limited to what he tells us in
the scripture yeah okay and the
scripture you choose to you choose to
follow is the Bible yeah okay and then
obviously the scripture I choose to
follow is the
Quran and so my own obviously like
you're making you know the claim about
having a son um these types of things
the answer that I personally would have
um and I may be wrong about this but we
believe as Muslims that having a son is
not indicative of power that having a
son is actually a sign of weakness
because it is not befitting of God's
unlimited all powerful nature to have a
son in the first place that the fact
that God has a son is actually a sign of
being of less status because it
indicates the fact that he would need a
son for example right that the Bible
claims that g that God sent down Jesus
to die for our sins as a way of
forgiving us as a way of wiping out the
sins of the world so that we could be
reunited with him and we can have a
connection with him correct how how does
how does God having a son uh show that
he needs a son if he had one I'm just
trying to explain it in terms you
understand so like do you agree that in
the Bible the narrative is that God sent
Jesus as his son to come and forgive the
sins of the world I yeah that has
nothing to do with the problem that's
being posed here it absolutely does so
in this sense that God is you're saying
that God is creating the sun in order to
do work on behalf of him and that is
necessary we don't believe that the son
is created so that's again jumping to
Christian and a misrepresent
misrepresentation of what Christians
believe and what the Bible teaches okay
incarnated in flesh you believe that it
was necessary to be incarnated in flesh
in order for sins to be forgiven for us
why is that because we needed a
sacrifice because we couldn't represent
ourselves we can't if God will to
forgive you he could not forgive you on
his own well he's just so he has to
punish sin so he can't he can't do that
but again sin impinges upon a person
respectfully this is off the subject you
understand what I'm saying yeah you need
to demonstrate to me how Allah having a
son demonstrates that he needs a son so
the Quran in response to this in says
that he is exalted above having a son so
what can we what can we extrapolate from
this what does exalted above having a
son means means that we we are not
making a claim whether he is physically
capable of having a son or not we're not
making that claim well that's what I'm
that's what I'm asking is HE capable I
cannot speak on that this the Quran
verbatim does not say whether he can
capably physically have a son or not it
is there's no we can try to logically
deduce ourselves but I think that would
be a disservice to my religion and
disservice to the scripture to speak on
something of my own logical conclusion
and give attributes to God which he does
not give to himself well the Quran is
actually pretty clear on this it says
that he can't do it unless he has a
consort where does it say that 6101
would you like to read that for me
verbatim yeah it says he is the
originator of the heavens and the Earth
how can he have a son when he doesn't
have a conso okay that's great so it
presents it as a question to the
response the people of qu who make the
claim that God has Partners God has
children God has Sons so this is one
example of a specific response that God
has to a group of people this example of
Quran is called this is a example of God
responding to a specific Claim by A
specific group of people yeah they
wasn't they wasn't they wasn't claiming
that he had a companion like he had a
girlfriend that was his no they were
claiming that he can have children right
exactly and the thing is that you have
to understand that Allah subhana in the
Quran says I know dude gr I know that
it's a response against the pagans I
know he's he's refuting their accusation
that he has a son how does he refute it
by saying that he doesn't have a partner
to have a son with absolutely yes this
is one example to make it understandable
to the people of qu how it is impossible
for God to have a son this is one
example it's important to understand
that you cannot take one verse out of
the Quran and then use it to become an
absolute response to
everything there vers can I finish
please can I finishe ahead you cannot
take one verse and and say okay this is
one response that God made to a specific
claim and this is the only response
there is because there's other responses
to this claim it says that he has not
been created and he has not does not beg
nor has he been begotten It also says
that he is exalted above having a son
and it also says that he doesn't have a
mate this is not an absolute saying that
God is incapable of having a son without
a partner he poses it as a question to
the qu which saying that you understand
in a human sense because he's speaking
to humans here he's not speaking to some
alln knowledgeable other being he's
speaking to humans and the humans from
their understanding is that when you
have a child what does it require it
requires a man who is fertile it
requires a woman who is fertile it
requires sexual reproduction it requires
a 9-month carrying sentence these are
what these people understand and so when
these people also assume that God also
has children they're also making the
claim in their eyes and in the eyes of
the Muslims that they're making the
claim that God himself is doing this so
God is responding to them and saying how
do you attribute children to me when I
don't have a mate because in their sense
you need a mate to have children it's a
stop because I let you talk for a very
very long time so no you can't assume
that they're the ones that they're
saying that he has a mate they didn't
say that they're just saying that he has
a son they don't they never ascribe a
mate to him you never see that in the
Quan but you see them continuously
ascribe to him daughters right or
children whatever so that's what you see
them ascribe to him his reputation and
you're right they know in order to have
children or at least the Quran knows
that in order for humans to have
children they need a mate to have a son
they need mate to have kids so how does
he refute them by using their own logic
he says how can I have a son when I
don't have a mate
so he's refuting them like it's it's
impossible for him to have a son because
he has no mate and he doesn't have no
mate because there's nobody equal to him
right he's he's above that so there's no
one equal to him and so therefore
there's no mate for him to have and
therefore say there's no mate for him to
have then therefore he doesn't have a
son so it refutes them what does this
all tell us it tells us that he just
showed us that in order for him to have
a son he needs a mate which deposes
right which is he did the reputation how
can I have a son when I don't have a
mate so he's not all powerful he can't
do it by
himself yes I so there is like two
methods in when it comes to interpreting
any text you can interpret something
defensively or you can interpret
something offensively in the sense you
are taking a more offensive
interpretation in the sense that you're
reading the Quran to through a Christian
lens and I agree that if you want to
twist this word this ver that way you
definitely twist it rain did I did I
twist it or did I just readin I think I
think you're interpreting it in a way
that it was not intended to be
interpreted and I don't think any book
of T ever says this if you can me a book
of that actually interprets it this way
yeah yeah when you read the toser ioc he
actually breaks it down exactly kind of
exactly how we just said it that um he's
refuting does it say that that God is
incapable of doing certain things that's
what I'm saying but what he says is
that's exactly what I'm
saying because of the result of another
can finish what absolute refutation let
me let me show you what iir says iir say
he says he understands it this way that
guys please you you don't have to mute
him it's okay it's okay Christina um I'm
you can go ahead and unmute your mic
R it's okay um so I says it he says not
that he got that Allah is incapable of
having a son he doesn't put it in that
those words ex however what he does say
is is that this shows that he doesn't
have a partner all right he doesn't have
somebody to partner with a companion
with to have a son with right and so
therefore he doesn't have a son so this
accusation that Allah has a son is
futile it's wrong like he understands it
that way that this is a reputation to
that now the problem is you know I
doesn't take it all the way to to his
logical conclusion but I I will I'm
taking it to all the way to it logical
conclusion that Allah in this verse
makes it clear that he is incapable of
having a son without having a mate which
completely refute the pagans because in
order to have a son you need a companion
you need somebody to mate with Allah
says he doesn't have that so he can't
have a
son yes because he is exalted above
having children and is exalted above
having a mate which you just said he's
more powerful than to have a mate there
are no equals to him no there's there's
it's not about powerfulness this shows
that he's not powerful enough to have
that's what I'm saying that you cannot
take one vert and use it as an absolute
reputation to a single argument when
this same argument has been refuted
multiple times throughout the Quran I
need this what argument specifically I'm
sorry what what argument has been refed
the argument that God cannot have
children this is refuted many places
across the Quran with different
reputations and so you have to look at
them holistically not one by one wait
just a second here okay let let's let's
talk about your view of be fits right be
fits because it talks about how he's
above having a son it doesn't be fit him
to have a son be be fitting or something
not fitting somebody to do something
just means that they're above doing that
doing that thing their their status is
higher to do something like that is is
to lower their status right is to you
know um you know it's it doesn't beit
them to do so like for example
does it beit a king to sleep in MAA
Palace
rain I think a humble King should does
it be fit a king to do so absolutely I
don't think it contradicts the idea of a
king to be a servant in and of itself I
I agree but does it befit the king to
get up to sweep and mop the palace is
that what a king does is that his
job I'm just going to Grant this to you
for the sake of the argument but it
really like there there's a logical flaw
on this example you probably bring a
different one that's better but I'm I
don't think that there's a logical flaw
in this example because we're just
talking about status cuz I think that we
both agree that a king has the ability
to sweep and mop the palace but I also
think that you and I can agree If we're
honest that it doesn't beit the king to
sweep and mop the palace that's for the
servants to do could we agree there so
there's an example I can actually bring
from this from the SRA of prophet
Muhammad that the Kings and the the
leaders of the qur tribe would
personally hand out water to the ha the
people making pilgrimage they would feel
this as a great honor to go and serve
other people and this was befitting of a
king at that time to go and serve others
and do the work that people thought
servants should do the kings actually
did it themselves because they thought
that it was a way to honor people honor
their tribe and honor themselves that
service the kings are not actually above
service
Kings do you have a Hadith that shows a
king sweeping him up in the palace I
just told you we have Hadith from the of
the Prophet if you want to read the
sealed nectar of the people ofr the
Kings leers of qur went and handed out
cups of water to the yeah handing out
cups and water is not sweeping and
cleaning the equivalent in their sense
they didn't have a palace that's the
that's an act of service it's a Act of
servant that servants usually do when
say someone bring F no that's a false
equivocation you're saying that you're
saying that them going out and ser and
serving water is the same as a king
going down and and sweeping and mopping
the palace floor that's the equivalent
of the K Society they didn't have a
palace floor that's a false equivocation
that you're making not a false
it's it's two people who are of exalted
status doing work that servants usually
do that's perfect so to you it be fits a
king to to mop and sweep the palace Flor
all right no problem um does does it
does it be fit a king to um to ride in
his own to to ride the horse of his own
Carriage to drive drive drive drive his
Carriage instead of riding can we just
get to the point well that's I'm I'm
trying to find
a common ground can you just give me
your definition of be fit and we can
talk about it I did so a be fit means
something that is fitting to a status of
a person that if something doesn't beit
them that means that that thing is uh
it's below them to do not that they're
incapable of doing it but it's below
them to do that thing would you agree
that that's what befitting
is you could say that okay so just
because something is not befitting of of
someone doesn't mean that they are
incapable of carrying out that action
carrying out that task or doing that
thing Allah it not befitting Allah to
have a son does not mean Allah is not
capable of having a son you know it just
says that he's above doing that he
wouldn't do that not that he can't right
so can I just be honest like can we just
like you know what I mean with this I
personally cannot speak
to exactly what God can and can't do
because in this sense right that this
question itself is kind of confusing
because like how do we Define son we I
think we can both agree that like God
the Father like what you believe is God
the father and Allah are kind of the
same sense in the sense that they are
the the one without like that that trans
that is the highest kind of the has the
hierarchy like the father is greater
than I in that sense that the father is
kind of what we think of as a and in
this sense that we don't believe that
like like Allah in and of itself has DNA
or like these types of attributes so
what actually is a son is a son just a
physical is a sun in the sense that the
Christian church is mentioning the Sun
as a pH physical manifestation of God
himself is it a sun in the sense of
paternity as in having your DNA injected
into another human being with a father
and a mother because we know that it
takes 48 chromosomes to make a human
being so the question itself is a little
confusing in that sense I'm just being
honest here this isn't an argument but
in that sense you kind of have to Define
sun in order to make this make sense so
now we're at a place where now we don't
know what son means when Allah says that
he's above having a
son um where he says that he uh needs a
mate to have a
son now we don't know what son means and
this is where when it comes to these
type of
discussions it illuminates more more and
more the the false Narrative of the
Quran man this stuff is supposed to be
clear it's supposed to be detailed I
think it's really clear that God is one
he doesn't have any children he doesn't
have any partners he doesn't have any
people associated with him I think
that's the clearest thing ever and it
gave me a lot of Peace it makes a lot of
sense to me it makes me a better person
fine I think in that sense like you
calling it confusing I mean the people
people make the same argument about the
Bible right a sense I didn't say this
was confusing right you did you said it
was confusing no no you just said it was
confusing you said that this question is
confusing um because now you got to
actually dive into how you know how you
define son what does son mean because
you're making me argue on a hypothetical
that will never happen can God have a
will can God have a son there's no point
in diving into that hypothetical because
he will never have a son when you try to
bring in things that are not evidenced
in the Quran and theith and the then
it's difficult to argue around it
because I have to sit here and do
logical jumps when it's not explicit
written can
a son is not logically and explicitly
written in the Quran so now I have to go
and start doing logical definitions with
you and establish a basis to build off
of right right who brought up this
hypothetical do do I bring up this
hypothetical or does the Quran bring up
this
hypothetical no the people of qures
brought up the hypothetical and then
Allah responded to them no even Allah
brings it up himself even without them
even without responding to them he he
brings it up himself he brings it up
multiple times of him a son the
hypothetical of him having a son he even
says that if he had a son say to
Muhammad he says say if Allah had a son
I'd be the first to worship him that's
4381 so Allah is the one bringing up and
dealing with these hypotheticals not me
I'm just I'm just thinking about them
and bringing the questions out when
Allah is the one who's who brings up
these hypotheticals you
know hypothetical here if it's oh you
you were you were paused R I didn't hear
what you said when whenever you're like
off the app I can't hear you oh I was
looking up the verse you mentioned okay
if you if you want to take a second like
we can take a second and look at it no
but basically what I'm saying is the
hypothetical is not whether God has a
son or not that's what Allah is
responding to it's saying say if Allah
has a son it's about if he can if he has
a son not if he can have a son so these
are two different things that one the
one the one talking about capability
versus attribution yeah no so the one
that I'm talking the one that I just
brought out was attribution the one that
we've been talking about this entire
time in chapter 6101 is about capability
that's what not about capability it is
because he says how can saying we're
making it about capability but that was
not the intention or the interpretation
of the scholar well that's but that's no
it is the intention because it's showing
that it's impossible for him to have a
son since he has no mate thus refuting
the pagans that he has a son he doesn't
have a mate so therefore he can't have a
son so stop saying he has a son guys he
can't do it he doesn't have a
mate that's that's the argument brother
I I think the the argument is that he is
exalted above having
both because having a physical son
requires 48 chromosones a male zygote
and a female
zygote and Allah is exalted above having
all these things and having a physical
hand takes DNA and veins and things of
this nature but you believe Allah has a
hand right not in a physical sense this
is a beautiful so why can't can't can't
Allah have a son in a non-physical
sense that's why I said you have to
Define son what is a son so exalted is
he above having a son because there's no
need for a son in a non-physical sense
what is a what is a son in a non no need
for anything bro like nobody's
addressing need I'm not I'm not saying
that Allah needs to have a son that's
not my argument so that's why I'm saying
that the Quran does not speak about
whether he can do this yes it does it
said look if I were to say I bring up
the last example that I brought up with
the previous guest you probably heard it
if I say how can I drive the car when I
don't have the keys based on that
statement what do I need in order to
drive the
car see this is actually an example I
wanted to bring up because this is an
example of you taking one verse and
extrapolating it against the entire on
bro come on R brother what do you need
to have a what do you need to drive a
car you need keys you need gas you need
a battery all right you need all sorts
of things nice but here's another thing
if you can fly why you drive a
car right exactly nice Allah is above
having a mate Allah is above driving a
car Allah having a son he is exalted
above these
things you're still not dealing with
this based upon my
question right based upon my statement
what am I saying I need in order to
drive the
car but I'm saying that Allah in this
sense is not giving an attribution about
himself or his needs he's giving an
attribution to a people so that they may
understand that to imply someone has a
physical son is to imply that they have
a
mateal equivalency in that sense not
answering I just answered it I said to
imply something has a physical son in
that sense to have a physical W that
this is to imply that they also have a
physical mate because that's how human
anatomy Works to have a son Allah says
so Allah is saying he's putting it in
terms in which they
understand do it
to I got you so order for Allah to have
a son he would need a physical mate in
order to have a
son to have a physical son humans need a
physical mate and so he is putting it in
terms that humans can understand because
he's responding to a quesi people assume
that a physical son is present in all
reques
generalities so to to make it capable to
make it capable to understand to the
quesi people that to have a son usually
requires a mate for these people and so
if you're going to ascribe a son to
Allah that means you also are ascribing
a mate to Allah but Allah is exalted
above this so you cannot do this why why
are you adding to the Quran don't do
that I'm taking every single verse in
context that's what I'm saying you're
taking and making assumptions about
Allah but he refutes these in other
verses you're not even listening to what
your own Quran says you absolutely am
I'm just quoting it and you don't want
to you don't want to accept the
explanation because it refutes your
respectfully you refuse to to answer my
analogy the question I asked based on my
analogy because you know the answer to
that um Everybody in the comment section
knows the answer to it you know the
answer you have your own I'm not gonna
argue with your comment section fam well
I'm just saying everyone knows this
everyone even you know this but for some
reason you refuse to answer the question
I think because you know what it would
lead to if you were to answer my analogy
when I asked please don't put words St B
stat what am I saying I need well if I
say how can I drive the car when I don't
have the keys what am I saying I need to
drive the car you know that I I'm saying
I need the keys you know that so when
Allah says how can I have a son when I
don't have a mate you know that Allah is
saying he needs a mate in order to have
a son therefore refuting the people
because he doesn't have a mate therefore
he doesn't have a son showing that Allah
is not all powerful man that does not
show Allah's all powerful it shows that
he is exalted of having this mate that
he that people are attributing to them
being exalted has nothing to do with
your power being
exed exaltation has to do with status
has to do with status not innate ability
you can have a high status like for
example uh it it's not befitting or the
CEO is so highly exalted that he's not
the telemarketer of the company he's not
going to be on the phone calling it
doesn't befit him to be on the phone uh
talking to customers about trying to get
leads
he's far above that he's the CEO of the
company not a telemarketer of the
company right does that doesn't mean
that the CEO doesn't have the ability to
go in the office move one of those dudes
Out The Way of the post put the
headphones on and say hi this is a how
how may I help you he's able to do that
even though it doesn't befit him as the
CEO to do that so exaltation is about
status not ability right here we're
talking about ability yes he's above
having a son I'm not addressing that I'm
addressing his ability to have one in
the first place and here he says he
can't unless he has a
mate do you understand that I'm saying
you cannot take one verse and use it to
holistically apply an attribution
without looking at the rest of the verse
on the on the subject right one of name
one of Allah's names is one that means
he cannot be divided he cannot be split
into parts and so when he says he is
Subhan he is exalted above something
he is giving a
humanoid version of how they like expect
Sons to be created and saying okay
you're claiming I don't have a son I
can't have a son I also cannot have a
mate okay so usually Sons come with
mates I don't have either why you look
in the rest of the Quran because he is
exalted above these things that Allah
has these attributes and having these
attributes does not make him any less
powerful if you ask Allah to do any of
these anything if you watch the creation
Allah created the heavens and the Earth
he exalted above all of this he exalted
above having a mate he's exalted above
having a child and so it's not saying
that he cannot do anything and also I
want to just point out a logical fallacy
within this that's saying for example as
I said before like can Allah create a
rock so heavy he can't lift it's a
contradiction within the question can
Allah attribute something that does not
beit his nature can Allah engage in a
contradiction because doing these things
would contradict his nature of it would
contradict his nature of being all power
I was waiting on you to say that I was
waiting on you to say that so you're
saying that it is a logical
contradiction a logical contradiction to
Allah's nature to have a son just like
it's a logical contradiction for him to
be able to create a rock so heavy that
he can't live you're saying that that's
the same thing in a sense okay so if
that's a logical contradiction and it
goes against his nature and you're
saying Allah can't do it then why does
Allah say he can if he wanted to why
does Allah say if he wanted to have a
son he could where does it say that in
chapter
39:4 let's look at it if you're basing
this off of the idea that Allah's not
able to go against his nature well he
just told you that he can go against his
nature unless he's not telling us the
truth I guess what I said was that he
was exalted above doing these things
yeah but you said that he can't go
against his nature like him having a son
is equivalent to him creating a rock so
heavy that he can't live that's a
logical contradiction so you're saying
that that's the same thing it's in the
same bar Park it's a logical
contradiction it goes against the nature
of a to have a son it logically
contradicts his
nature Allah says he can logically
contradict his nature then he says he
can have a son if he
wanted in the sense that he says right
that you need these two things to have a
to have a child in most senses and he
says he he is exalted above doing this
now I may have misspoke in saying that
it is a logical contradiction but that
is not from Islam that is from me that
is my own deficiency fair enough so I
made that mistake and that's why I said
like in a sense because I really didn't
I don't know exactly how to make those
jumps and make those equivalencies I can
make an argument on behalf of Islam or
the Quran if I make my own issues within
logical reason that's my own fault and
I'm not going to say I'm perfect that's
why I said I'm an issue and if anyone
wants to you know fault me for this
that's okay no you're you're you having
this type of attitude is admirable and I
hope that everybody especially the the
Christians listening to this I hope that
you guys honor this person because he's
he's humble enough to say you know what
maybe I misspoke on this and so I made I
misspoke about it's beautiful yeah I
misspoke about a logical argument I did
not miss misspeak about the Quan and I
did not missp about Allah's attributes
all right do not disprove Islam it does
not disprove Allah's attributes it just
proves that I have a issue within my own
logical reasoning in that sense and I
spoke and said something I shouldn't
have said okay so going on now further
with this so now we see that I guess
having a son does not necessarily go
against Allah's nature doesn't it's not
a logical contradiction however he is
above doing it and we already get that
he's above doing it he's above having a
son he's he's it doesn't beit him to do
this however it says that he could if he
wanted to now now there's also caveat
with this though he could if he wanted
to but he would need a mate to do it so
he would have to create for him a mate
so what I'm say is that you're
interpreting this verse very literally
that's what it says but I'm saying that
Allah obviously does not attribute to
himself a mate which is why he can't
have a son by himself he needs help but
it doesn't say that he can have a son by
itself does it say in this verse that
had had God's will been to have
Offspring he would have gotten a wife
and then he would have had children well
no so see it it it I see this is where
your idea of taking the Quran as a whole
comes into play because here he says he
can have a son if he wanted to right he
doesn't mention how he just mentions
that he can do it if he wanted to now
the how comes in 6101 how can he do it
with a mate that's the only way he can
do it yes but he is exalt above having a
mate I got you which means that and
that's fair he's exalted above having a
mate can I speak which means that but he
can't have a son without a m that's the
only point but that I'm telling you that
he is not saying within his own
capabilities he's trying to relate it to
the people of qur that's the way that
I'm interpreting and that's also the way
that c interpreted it as the way that
you said you said that he didn't make
that jump to say that Allah
needs right the way you explained it you
said
that he doesn't he doesn't make the leap
explicitly saying that Allah needs a
mate to have a son he doesn't say that
explicitly but that's you know he you
know he doesn't say it explicitly but
you that's what I'm saying that that
when we make these jumps and try to
attribute things to Allah that which he
does not say we step into the gray area
and which we're trying this is a gray
area this isn't a gray area this is a
clear this is super clear it's
I me if it was I'm not I think you know
we've established like I'm not stupid if
it was super clear I would admit it I'm
not here to lie I don't think so I don't
think so because this is something look
look you're you're right you you are an
intelligent young dude you know but at
the same time you being intelligent and
you're humble at the same you you got a
lot of qualities working for you Ray you
got a lot of qualities working for you
however that doesn't mean that you're
willing to admit everything I don't
think so I'm saying that for
me as a person right yeah I used to be
Christian I
did I promise you I can show you all the
proof you want we
we show me
right pictures of your bapt y about to
see I will send you a video of my
baptism I swear to God I was okay and so
I am a person who genuinely seeks after
the truth in God who genuinely did his
research who genuinely spent time with
high Scholars of the church I'm not
talking about I was watching sham Sam
Shimon on YouTube trying to learn about
Christianity that I sat there with
church fathers my mother worked at the
church I stayed there four days out of
the week I went to youth group I went to
church every Sunday I learned as much as
possible and it was the main issues that
I did
have and led me towards Islam also
caused me to be very very devout when it
came to Islam and I did my research I
studied for the past two years I've been
studying alhamdulillah I still don't
know a lot because I'm new but in that
sense that if there is something wrong
and I I was being disingenuous I I
wouldn't lie I promise you I wouldn't
and that's why I was able to admit that
I made a logical mistake but I'm telling
you that IB C in this sense also agrees
with me that this does not you cannot
jump and make that conclusion based on
this no see that see that's that's what
I'm correcting you on I doesn't agree
with you he he the only part that he
agrees with you on is that Allah is
above having a partner and you know that
he's showing that he doesn't have a
partner right and he's above that and
he's above having a son however he he
relates him having a partner to him
having a son okay now he doesn't make
the jump and say well and come to the
conclusion that Allah is incapable of
having a son without a mate he doesn't
say that
explicitly however yes because that
conclusion cannot be Lo cannot be jumped
from that that's a different subject
it's not a jump we're speak on Allah's
capabilities speaking on Allah's
capabilities versus speaking on human
capabilities are two different things
all right yeah when Allah is talking
about how can I he's talking about his
own capability
right I'm saying that he's speaking to
humans in a sense that they would
understand yeah speaking to humans about
his ability right
he's speaking to humans so like I said
before right when humans need to have
children when I said humans need to have
children they need a mate right help me
help me so in order to have children in
a human sense you need a mate we know
he's talking to
humed he's talking to humans about his
own ability right when he says how can I
talking to humans saying ability he's
talking about his attribute how can I
whenever you say how can is that not
dealing with
ability give me give me an example of a
how can statement that's not dealing
with your
ability that's why I'm saying that it's
it's not in a sense of ability it's an
sense of exaltation when you use it in
light of the other verses do it for me
do it for me give me an example of a how
can statement that's not dealing with
ability would you like me to go and look
through and find that for you I mean I
don't know exactly what this I'm trying
to understand like if we want to have
like a difference you know agree to
disagree on this we can do it but I'm
telling you and I don't think you're
getting it that making The Logical jump
from him in his nature not doing
something he's asking them how is it
possible for a son to be created without
a mate Allah is exalted above having
both he do say that
unfortunately but that's how you that's
how I'm interpreting it in like the
other verses nice that that's that's
fine that's fine and I look let me
actually repeat your argument your POS
I'll still man it to show you that I
understand what you're saying you're
saying that this verse it's not talking
about what Allah is not able to do it's
not talking about what he's not capable
of doing but it's talking about his
majesty and that he is a above having a
mate in the first place and he's above
having a son in the first place and so
the other verses surrounding this
subject talk about how Allah it doesn't
befit him to be a son it doesn't befit
him that you should ascribe to him a son
he's above that so here it's talk it
it's it's it's referring to really
Allah's Majesty in him being above
having a mate there's nobody equal to
him there's no one with him and so he's
above that is that your is that your
position s someone called I swear
someone called me in the middle of you
talking and it cut cut out aart I swear
to
God someone facetimed me for like two
seconds you you said that is it my
position that God is above having a mate
this is this is my position yes yes so I
so I just want you to know that I am
able to steal man position I can
strengthen it and like show you that yes
I understand fully what you're saying I
understand fully your position I'm not
misrepresenting you I'm not confused
about what you're saying I know exactly
what you're saying here's my position
okay I am aware that all that verses
surrounding this topic talk about Allah
being above having a son and above
having a partner having a companion I
understand that his status is above that
however status does not deal with
capability so my argument
is wait let me know I'm I'm not asking
I'm not asking you to I'm just stating
my position just like I stated yours let
me State my position okay I
understand that he is above that which
is not my argument my argument isn't
about Allah's status and Majesty my
argument is about his capability
when he in this verse in all the other
verses he addresses his ability I mean
I'm not I'm sorry his his status there's
a few verses where he addresses his
capability like the one I showed you
about where he says if he wanted to have
a son he could that's he could he has
the ability to he addresses his ability
there here again he addresses his
ability to have a son but here he says
he can do it with a mate yeah like he
can't do it without a mate that is my
issue where he's not talking about how
he's above having a mate even though
other verses say he is but here
specifically he's dealing with his
ability and says how can I have a son
when I don't have a
mate so it's not capable of all for
Allah to have a son without a
mate that's my that's my problem
that's interpretation that is it's not
possible you're saying it's not possible
for Allah to have a son without a
mate what I'm saying is that's not what
this verse is saying we have a
difference of opinion if the the T also
does not say this in that logical jump
that he's not capable of having a son
without a mate so there's no Islamic
source that says this directly there's
no quranic source that says the Quran
Source says it directly that's all
that's my point but if the Quran source
is being interpreted by classical
Scholars who are of the utmost knowledge
about these
subjects then how can you and you say
your interpretation your extrapolation
is better than than their see you're
you're assuming that iir is goes against
my position he doesn't he doesn't
address my position he doesn't he he's
he's he's look let me let's just go to
what iir says really quick let's just go
to what he says really quick man can you
give me the verse number again please
chapter 6 verse 101 all right so look
this I this is toughs here okay I have
the bridged version in English so there
might be more in the Arabic I don't know
if you know Arabic you may be able to
bring that out or something
but for now this is what we have okay so
look when he addresses this how can he
have children when he has no wife all
right he says for the child is The
Offspring of two compatible
spouses Allah does not have an equal
none of his creatur are similar to him
for he alone created the entire creation
Allah said you know and starts talking
about you know they you know they say
that he begot a
son indeed you have brought forth a
terrible things you know starts quot sah
19 y y right so he has created
everything and is all know of all things
how can he have a wife from from his
creation who is suitable for his majesty
when
there is none like him how can he have a
child look look how can he have a child
then verily Allah is glorified above
having a son so even iir understands
this look he doesn't have anyone equal
to him he doesn't have a suitable
partner to to to have a Offspring with
right so therefore he can't have a son
and is above is is above doing
this you see what I'm saying yeah so so
yeah what I'm saying in this sense is
that it doesn't speak explicitly on
Allah's capabilities that can he not do
it by himself it doesn't say that it
says as another line of argumentation
against the that there's multiple lines
of argumentation Allah uses first he's
exalted second that he is the originator
second that another that he doesn't have
a mate because these are all things to
frame their understanding but you see
that when Allah is addressing
specifically the Believers uses
different terminology and so when it
comes to Allah saying that I that that
how can I have children or how can he
have it doesn't say how can I it says
how could he have children when he has
no Allah speaking
right well the entire Quran is the
speech of Allah yes yeah but it's a a
response so here Allah is
telling the prophet to relay to the
people ofr right because this is an
example of right a reason for Revelation
where the made a claim and Allah subhana
is giving the prophet wasallam a
response to the qur exactly a reputation
yes so to say that he is the originator
of the heavens and the Earth how could
he have children when he has no mate
what I'm saying is I understand where
you're coming
from but the interpretation of the does
not say that he is incapable of having a
CH child without a mate it's saying that
because these people are used to the
concept that a child is the result of
two suitable spouses and Allah does not
even have a spouse if even if you wanted
to attribute children to Allah you
couldn't because Allah does not have a
spouse in that sense it's not saying
that he is it is impossible for do
certain things because we cannot speak
on whether and what Allah can do this is
in that we cannot understand exactly
what see notice how you said what i is
not saying that's not how he interprets
it he doesn't say that he's responding
to it in a way that they understand no
this is a a straightup response to
refute no I'm saying that that is how
you
understand that's not what says here
look even understand look look just
please I'm trying to give you the
connotation of what Sab means it is for
the to understand it is not for the
Believers it is not it is not addressing
a believer's claim it is addressing or
addressing anyone else's claim it is
addressing spec specifically the claim
of the well is this not this not
addressing anyone who has anyone who
says that he has a son is this not
addressing any of them I'm saying that
in this specific example who is Allah
talking to he's talking to the people
ofr that's that's true and the people
ofr can we can also if we would like to
look at the Hadith in which the cont
context in which this verse was revealed
because they do have those I haven't
looked into it myself I haven't looked
into the actual complete circumstance of
where this was revealed it is known okay
so where is the about the claim of do
you know what the claim of ques was that
they that he has children specifically
that he has daughters like like verba I
was asking but it's okay so look bro
this is the how he interprets this how
can he have a children when he has no
wife he breaks it down for the child is
The Offspring of two compatible spouses
yes Allah does not have an equal none of
his creatures are similar to him for he
alone created the entire creation so he
goes on to back up that with verses so
then he he uh completes it he created
everything and he is knower of all
things how can he have how can there's
ability again he have a wife from his
creation who is suitable for his majesty
when there is
no when there is none like him when
there is none like him how can he have a
child
then verily Allah is glorified above
having a son in order for Allah to be
able to have a son he would need an
equal
mate he doesn't have an equal mate
therefore he can't have a
son yeah I'm saying this is a reputation
he's not making a claim that he cannot
have a son with by himself okay then his
his reputation is not valid
then to to him for him to for him to use
that as a reputation for it to not be a
true valid reputation is silly well
that's your classification of it it
obviously worked because all the almost
all the people converted tolam imagine
this wait hold on what was my topic
imagine this uh rain
imagine Allah is
addressing the Refuge a of the pagans
I'm sorry the argument of the pagans
he's addressing it and he's coming to
refute it but he's using an argument
that actually doesn't work because he
can actually have a son without a mate
he doesn't need a mate to have a son
so but they didn't know that they didn't
claim that he had a
mate that's what I'm saying that thees
were pagans they didn't understand they
were Idol worshippers they many
times they would claim things that that
were not true they would claim that
Idols are God they would claim that
angels are are women and Daughters of
God they would claim all these crazy
things so he's explaining it to the wa
wait you just lag you just lag that
fam had bro so what I was
saying that Allah in this verse is is
explaining this explaining the the
cohesive term right the overarching idea
is that Allah cannot have children he
explaining this to the in a way that
they can understand it is he saying that
he does he say in the Quran that he is
incapable
of incapable of doing anything except by
his own will and except by his own
actions indivisibly ahead no he does not
say that over and over in the Quran he
can do everything he Wills he does what
he Wills he can do it by himself ex he's
explaining this he's not he's saying it
to the in a way that they can understand
it so he's using a false reputation then
no worri I'm not it's not a false
reputation it is it doesn't understand
it and it worked no it doesn't because
it doesn't apply to look imagine me
using a false representation to your
claim um it doesn't really work but you
you can't refute it so I win but it's a
false rep reputation anybody sharp
enough to to know that wait you're your
reput my you're not addressing my actual
argument your reputation doesn't apply
to you because actual argument God
doesn't have children so it doesn't it's
saying that God all he has to do is just
say he doesn't have children he does so
many
times no but see look using I I don't
have a mate so therefore I don't have
kids if he doesn't need a mate to even
have kids in the first place is a silly
reputation because it doesn't apply to
Allah but I'm saying that they did not
understand this and it says also that
Allah is exalted above having a mid
exalted above having children all right
bro the all right we could we could rest
that here did you uh want to bring up
something or was that it I mean we can
talk about anything you'd like that
that's that's the only argument I had
maybe on another like yeah like I think
wholeheartedly wholeheartedly I've done
my
research and this is the conclusion I've
come upon I think that I've seen a few
of your videos before there are some
things that I like disagree with that
you did but I I don't really have them
off the top of my head I think I made a
video actually responding to one of you
things before but it's
okay yeah you didn't you didn't respond
to my arguments you you said that I was
just attitude yeah you should be a
little bit nicer you know no he wasn't
he mocked why why didn't you address him
when he mocked saying your God was on
the cross begging and stuff why why
didn't you say something about that that
wasn't that wasn't appropriate and I
said it in the comment section as well
you said in the comment you didn't say
it in your making your video you only
addressed us for having this meeting him
with his same energy I'm deficient
because of that I like you man I I
almost said I love you almost maybe one
more meeting I would say I love you but
if you're you're you're you're see
that's my thing about you man you're you
could be honest and say yeah you know I
made a mistake
[Music]
he